hi i'm danny ceo and here's a brand new
episode of do
just one thing
how do you wrap a bottle of wine and
believe it or not
it's as simple as using a sheet of
newspaper a pair of sharp scissors
and just a little bit of time to create
this
a really beautiful festive kind of
sparkling fireworks
inspired wrapped bottle of wine and yes
i did say a newspaper
so what you want to do is just go
through your recycling bin
and find an old newspaper or any kind of
paper will really do
so if you have a leftover grocery store
bag a paper grocery store bag you can
also rip that open and use that as
your bottle wrapper and the way that it
works is that you take
a couple of sheets of newspaper just
like this
and it's as simple as wrapping the
bottle
all the way around like this and what
you want to end up with
is the base of the bottle
is flush with the edge of the newspaper
make it really really tight and take one
piece of tape and just tape it in place
now if you went to the party or
something like this this is not a
beautifully wrapped bottle the way that
you transform this into this
is really simple you can take a rubber
band or in this case i have
just an old shoestring or a piece of
string
and you find the middle of the neck of
the bottle
and what i like to do is just tie a
notch
or you can do a bow and make sure it's
really really snug because this will be
another way of securing the paper to the
bottle
and then here's where the magic begins
is that you just take
the edge of the newspaper so this is the
clean edge right here and about
every inch or so you just cut down with
your scissors
going around and around making strips
and
these are the strips that we're gonna
transform into beautiful curls
in one easy step by the way this is a
great thing to do with leftover gift
wrap during the holidays
so don't buy new wrapping paper
use what you have and be as resourceful
as possible
okay and then you end up with this so
still not
quite there from this to this and this
is the one thing that you do
to make it really special is you take
your scissors open them up
and what i like to do is take one or two
of the strips
and you run it across the blade of the
knife if it breaks it's totally fine
because you got plenty of strips
you just run it across the blade of the
knife
and you see how it instantly curls so
take one or two
and you can do the whole strip you can
do part of the strip
it doesn't matter because the goal is
once they get a little bit curly
they take on a little bit of a
personality
and for me i think one of the best gifts
you can bring someone during the
holidays whether it's a bottle of wine
but if you're bringing champagne
this actually looks like an exploding
bottle of champagne
you can take those little um do you see
those shears for sewing you can also add
a little bit of decoration on the edge
if you want
or you can just be really simple and
just keep curling away
you see guys in just a matter of seconds
we took a piece of tape a couple of
strips of newspaper
and some scissors a rubber band
and look at this now i have two
beautifully wrapped
festive upcycled gift wrapped bottles of
wine
ready to go for my party so easy do just
one thing if you're gonna wrap some
bottles of wine this summer and you're
posting it to your social media be sure
to tag
the drew barrymore show tag in all of
your posts and check out more projects
recipes and inspiration
at thedrewberrymoreshow.com and don't
forget
as you're sipping your vino enjoy it
with the brand new issue of my magazine
naturally danny ceo now on newsstands
[Music]